the one october memorial committee is
hearing the thoughts of thousands who
took a survey focused on what a future
memorial should include it will
eventually be built at the site of the
route 91 harvest festival 73 percent of
respondents felt education should be a
significant component with support for
the following stories of community
heroism mental health survivor stories
and lessons learned by first responders
in the hospitality industry there was
also discussion about whether or not
people should be allowed to leave
mementos at the site without any
restrictions focus groups suggest they
should be limited or perhaps not allowed
out of maintenance concerns
the families will be worked with closely
to determine
what they're comfortable with what
holidays etc special events for mementos
to be placed
when it comes to the artistic side
respondents backed the idea of having
references to country music and a
symbolic representation of those who
died
and jason aldean is remembering his
security guard ryan fleming in his post
he shared that fleming was the one who
saved him he pulled him off the stage
that night when the shots rang out of
the festival his cause of death though
was not released